[موسيقى]
من مكه الى الرياض خاض المواطن السعودي
عبد الرحيم السلمي رحله امل والهام واضع
لعاقته التي اصيب بها خلف ظهره مؤكدا ان
لا ياس بعد الاعاقه عبد الرحيم قطع نحو
900 كم في 32 يوما وهو على مشارف الوصول
الى الرياض في هذه الايام يطمح بالوصول
اليها رغم تعب الطريق وضجت مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي بفيديوهات عبد الرحيم الذي تحدى
الاعاقه سيرا على راحلته التي نقلته من
مكه الى الرياض وهو بكامل نشاطه في سبيل
مواصله الرحله اليوم سيكون معنا عبد
الرحيم للحديث عن الرحله والالهام والامل
وكيف تحدى الاعاقه ليكون مثالا اعلى
للجميع الاصحاء منهم قبل ذوي الهمم
[موسيقى]
من الرياض ينضم الينا الرحاله عبد الرحيم
السلامي عبد الرحيم يسعد صباحك اهلا بك
منورنا بصباح العربيه شكرا على تواجدك
معنا
يا صباح الخير والسرور يا هلا يا مرحبا يا
هلا عبد الرحيم يعني تحديت الاعاقه وقررت
خوض رحله من مكه الى الرياض وهي ليست
بالرحله السهله حدثنا اكثر عن فكره هذه
الرحله والهدف منها
الهدف من الرحله طبعا لا الاعاقه
عندي اعاقه باتر فوق الركبه الرجل اليمنى
والحمد لله هدفي من الرحله
لاخواني البتور والاحتيالات الخاصه كافه
من مكه الى
العاصمه الرياض
وبنتحدث عن مسافه كبيره جدا يعني اذا بدنا
نتخيلها جغرافيا يوم عبد الرحيم في مرات
شعرت بالاستسلام شعرت بالضعف انه انا مش
قادر اكمل هاي الرحله
ابدا ابدا لم اشعر بالاستسلام ولا بالياس
اني او بالندم اني فكرت في هذه الرحله
بالعكس يعني فيها من المشاق وفيها من
التعب لكن الحمد لله
المعنويات والاصرار
ضغطت على التعب والمعنويات ما في رحله مثل
هذه يكون في ما فيها تعب لابد ان فيها تعب
وفيها مصاعب شوي لكن الحمد لله تخطينا
جميع المصاعب وما في اي مشاكل ولله الحمد
طيب عبد الرحيم الرفيق في هذه الرحله هي
الناقه هل جهزتم الناقه بتجهيزات ومعدات
خاصه يعني نتحدث عن 900 كيلو متر في 32
يوم
نعم نعم في الشداد
محل ما اطلع على الناقه
صممتوه بلحيته انه لا
يثبت لي مزبوط على الناقه
وسويت حاضنه بديله عن الرجل المقطوره
والحمد لله لا توجد اي عاقه ابو عبد
الرحيم
احنا حابين نشوفها للناقه ونحييها نوجه
لها سلام من صباح العربيه وشو اسمها كمان
اسمه مطيع
وهذه الناقه خلفي اسمه مطيع هذه الرحول
الخلفي مطيع الان يا ريت الكاميرا مان هيك
يفرجينا اياها
لانه مش ايوه
وهي مطيعه ولا مطيعه يا عبد الرحيم
مطيع مطيع مذكر
يسمع الكلام طيب عبد الرحيم انت يعني
استشرت الطبيب قبل هذه الرحله نتحدث عن
رحله طويله يعني خصوصا انه فيها خطور
خطوره الوقوع من الناقه
نعم استشرت الاطباء وشعملت كشف طبي شامل
الحمد لله كل شيء سليم وبعدين
عندي خلفيه في طلوع على الابل وما في اي
صعوبه
الانسان اذا انه نوى على شيء يعمله بكل
صرار
اكيد يعني الحمد لله وصلنا الرياض بخير
وصحه وسلامه عبد الرحيم وين الوجهه بعد
الرياض كمان رح تكمل بالناقه
لا ان شاء الله انه الان اول شيء وجه
الشكر لاخواني لوزاره الرياضه انتظر منهم
يوجهوني للموقع اللي اوصله
وهنا تنتهي الرحله بالتوفيق يا عبد الرحيم
واحنا بنشكرك
يعطيك الف عافيه وشكرا لك الله يعطيك
العافيه عبد الرحيم السلمي